[Music]
i have the
pleasure today of speaking with dr brett
weinstein who
i met about five years ago an
evolutionary biologist
who taught at evergreen state college
until political
circumstances made it impossible for
that to continue
brett served as the moderator for
two discussions i had with sam harris is
that right
that is correct in vancouver i think
that was when that was the first time we
met in person wasn't it
uh i believe we met prior to that at
a conference in vancouver also um
a uh young libertarian oh oh yes that
group and the ubc group right that was
before
yeah well and we haven't spoken
since when vancouver
is that right uh it must have been more
recent than that in fact i'm certain it
was but it's been quite some time
well so we i thought it might be
interesting for us to catch up and to
share that
process of catching up on my youtube
channel
so and brett you have a youtube channel
and you have a podcast
which the image of which i believe is on
the wall a beautiful wall behind you
that
that's your kitchen that's all done in
cedar like that
no that's uh one half of my office that
we uh at the beginning
of covid my son and i my son produces
our podcast and we
built the studio in this room making
runs back and forth to the hardware
store and
uh bugging out of the uh the prior space
that we were in so anyway yes we erected
this in about
two days and uh you know the sync works
and uh
it's all it's functional but it's it's
basically my workspace in my office it
makes a lovely background
you have some skulls back there too i
sure do
i have skulls in my office interestingly
enough what are they
um well let's see we have back there a
bear and a seal and
the juxtaposition is important to
heather and to me because
seals are actually bears they evolved
they return to the sea
and their skulls are extremely difficult
to distinguish except for the teeth
you can tell by the teeth but otherwise
a seal skull looks like a bare skull to
an amazing degree
and so which one is the seal uh let's
see yeah well i'm gonna i would guess
that it's on the one on my right
the seal is the one closer to the plant
yes okay because i have a bear skull
which looks more like the one on the
left so
so um when did you start your podcast
well the podcast started geez i'm not
good at remembering these things exactly
but
the podcast started must be
about two years ago and then
it went through a radical transition at
the beginning
of covid where instead of just being a
show that we taped we moved it into this
room and heather and i started doing
weekly live streams which we still do or
i still do
separate discussions with people but the
weekly live streams have become
a really important component and what's
the live stream what do you do on the
live stream
well what we do is we point the
evolutionary lens
at important topics everything from the
woke
revolution to the fragility of
civilization
what future governance might look like
basically whatever interests us and it's
accumulated
quite a following it's been you know
it's never something that we intended to
do
but it turns out that there as you know
better than anyone
there's a huge hunger for
people who know something are willing to
talk courageously
in public and won't mislead you
right we can all be wrong but uh it's
rare enough that somebody will tell you
explicitly what they think and why and
uh
you know if you do that it's amazing how
many people will find you yeah well
people do have some desire for the truth
painful though that might be
yeah and you said you didn't expect to
be doing this
on a full-time basis there's no doubt
that life is full of
all sorts of twists and turns that you
don't expect
well that's certainly true and that
actually brings me um you know the way
you
you introduced this discussion didn't
give me a chance to say
by far the most important thing here
which is
it is so great to be talking with you
jordan
we were so worried about you and
i'm sure you're getting that message
loud and clear but at another level it's
probably
hard to appreciate um how
profound your absence from the
discussion has been
over the last year and i know you've
been to hell and back and we've been
experimenting with
hell on earth here while you were away
but uh
it is really really good to be with you
and um
anyway i think it's very important that
that just be the baseline for the
conversation welcome back
thank you that's so nice of you and
people have been so welcoming to me
you know with the exception of the odd
journalist let's say
but online people are so good to me that
i can't believe it it's
well there's many things i can't believe
that's certainly one of them
it's very nice to see you and you're
looking well thank you you as well
yeah well that's deceiving unfortunately
but
well at least you're headed in the right
direction can we say that that's
that's the theory and i'm able to work a
bit i'm working about two hours
every three days now i would say um
doing
this sort of thing which i also didn't
expect to be doing
as my major what what would you say as
my major occupation
my my area of occupation has shrunk
to a staggering degree over the last two
years
and that's been quite difficult to
contend with
um well i hope it's temporary
um but i mean from the outside enough so
that i can't be as functional as i used
to be but
i can't sit around and do nothing
because it drives me completely out of
my mind to do nothing i'm
used to being occupied all the time and
so but i'm very happy that i'm able to
do these discussions and so far that's
been going well
so i'd like you to walk me through
what's happened to you
since the events in evergreen
and and bring everybody up to date on my
end
so man maybe you could start with what
happened at evergreen although i suspect
many of the people watching this
do know that does that seem reasonable
sure um yeah we can we can start there i
think we should um probably
air in the direction of being sparse
with the details
and uh see where it leads us so
in 2017 i was teaching at evergreen as
was
heather my wife and she was literally
evergreen's
most popular professor i wasn't too far
behind i was very popular as well
our classes were always over full and
we accepted more people than we had to
and had to turn some away anyway
and then in actually 2016 the new
president of the college
george bridges began an initiative or a
set of initiatives
surrounding diversity equity and
inclusion and
these initiatives included the
impaneling of a committee
that was supposed to look into
racism at the college its impacts and to
propose solutions
and as it became clear what they were
alleging and proposing heather and i
became very alarmed
and i began to speak out at first in
faculty meetings and then when the
ability to speak out in faculty meetings
became non-existent i took to our
faculty and staff email list to talk
about
the threat to the college that was
created by these
initiatives and that of course brought
about
exactly what you would imagine which
were accusations that i was motivated by
some kind of
uh racism or white supremacy or white
fragility or who knows what the
accusations were exactly but
um but in any case i fought back anyway
and my sense was i had tenure
and i was well liked and i was well
known at the college i had been there
for 14 years
and so i didn't think they had the power
to
uh to get rid of me and that gave me the
ability to say what needed to be said
about these
proposals well the upshot is
that ultimately protesters
50 students that i had never met showed
up at my classroom
accused me of racism demanded that i
either be fired
or resign i told them i wouldn't
and riots broke out at the college in
which
faculty and administrators were
kidnapped i was apparently
hunted car to car on campus by
protesters
the police were stood down by the
college president
and we were basically left to fend for
ourselves
with student
patrols roving the campus with weapons
baseball bats and the like
so it was a chaotic scene there was
a lot of interest in it because it was
very
colorful but of course most people back
in 2017
dismissed this as yes an overreaction
but
you know how college students are and
those of us who saw it up close
knew that that couldn't be the case that
it would ultimately spill out into
civilization
and we of course were right
and now it's everywhere we see it taking
over institution after institution
in the u.s and canada we see it making
tremendous
strides in government and
there's no telling where it ends and
what is
i mean i have a bunch of questions that
come out of that
so i'm gonna i'll lay out three why in
the world
did this bother you enough so that you
took a stand
especially given your political leanings
because you were which i'm not
criticizing by the way i'm just
stating that it isn't obvious to begin
with why it would be you that would take
a stand say rather than someone else but
you did and so i'm curious about why
and um what is it that you saw coming
and what is this it that you're
referring to you've had a lot of
time to be thinking about this now it's
been four years and i mean
you're and the other thing i want to ask
you about is your life was thrown
completely upside down you and your wife
you don't have your job at the
university anymore either of you despite
the fact that you were tenured
professors
it's not an easy thing to get another
toe hold in academia
once you've been a tenured professor
somewhere especially if you've gone
through what you went through because no
hiring committee
anywhere is going to give you any
consideration
once you've been um once you've been
tarred by scandal
regardless of what your role in it was
they're far too conservative to ever do
anything like that
and so okay so let's i don't know if i
can remember the order in which i
i asked those questions but i think the
first one was
why in the world did you why in the
world were you compelled to
to object to object and what is it that
you were objecting to do you think
well it's a funny a funny question for
you to pose to me because i have the
feeling
that the answer will be entirely
native to you i literally don't believe
i had
any choice people frequently ask me why
i stood up
and my sense is if i think through the
alternative
i simply can't live with it i can't
sleep yeah but that doesn't seem to
bother most people so
i don't get that like why why you
well right i mean i guess that's the the
thing i'm discovering
um so you alluded to my political
leanings and you and i both know what
you mean by that
i'm a liberal and i would actually i
describe myself sometimes as a
reluctant radical
by that i mean that i believe
we must engage in radical change if we
are to survive
as a species but i also know that
radical change
is very dangerous and so it's not like
you know i find most people who would
call themselves radicals
feel like radical change is always
called for and i don't my
my sense is i hope to see
change that makes civilization good
enough that i get to be a conservative
that i get to say actually we're doing
so well
that we have no choice but to preserve
this if we try to improve it we'll mess
it up
that's where i want to go but what i'm
discovering is
that the bedrock of my
liberalism is nothing like
the underpinnings of the so-called
liberalism of most of the people on the
left side of the political spectrum
my liberalism comes from a sense that
yes
compassion is a virtue but that policy
must be based on a dispassionate
analysis
of problems it is based on an
understanding
that there that the magic of the west
comes from
a tension between those who aspire to
change things from the better for the
better and those
who recognize the danger of changing
them at all
and and so in any case i think
the short answer is we look around the
world
and everybody makes arguments that sound
as if they come
from first principles but most people do
not arrive at conclusions from first
principles
if they extrapolate at all they don't do
it very well
and that results in a severe
compartmentalization
of thought and that means that when
confronted
with changes
that threaten a system on which we are
dependent
most people don't recognize it and if
they do recognize that they wouldn't
know what to do about it
so uh how can i
how can i put it in in plain terms i had
no choice
because i was as if on a ship where
somebody had proposed
to fix our course through uh
a field of icebergs um and
navigate based on some absurd theory
with no
grounding in fact somebody had to object
and i was a little surprised
at how few and far between the objectors
were
but you know if i'm to be totally candid
about it at the point that things went
haywire
at evergreen i had watched video
of you reacting to protesters
in toronto and
it had made so much sense to me at a
number of different levels
you know i recognized you as somebody
who knew that although
the initial proposals were
arguably symbolic that they were
connected to things that ultimately were
very much about
an exercise of power and a transfer of
well-being
and that it was therefore
you know you felt obligated to stand up
and say no
which resulted as you know better than
anyone in you being
mocked for overreacting and then here we
are years later and it turns out that
you saw with absolute clarity what
others couldn't even imagine
yes but i certainly didn't see what was
going to happen to me
right you know so
i don't think it's root it wasn't
possible to see what would happen
with specificity but i th
am i correct in uh
seeing that you knew that something very
dramatic was likely to come
from your standing on principle and that
that didn't provide any license to do
anything
but make that stand
i i really can't say you know um
it's a it's a while ago now so that
that's part of it
but so much has happened to me that's
been so strange in the last four years
that i
have very difficult time making any
sense of it i can't even really
think about especially the last two
years i can't really think about them in
any
consistent and comprehensive way i mean
my my
family situation has been so
catastrophic in my illness and my wife's
illness it's just been
although she recovered completely thank
god
it's just been so utterly catastrophic
that that my my thinking about it is
unbelievably fragmented i'm
and i'm i'm
struck dumb still to some degree by
by all of what emerged as a consequence
of
me making the first videos that i made
you know i went downstairs
talked to my wife and my son my son was
living at home at that time
temporarily and i said this piece of
legislation is really bothering me
because it
calls for compelled speech and i looked
at the background
documents and something wasn't right and
i said i need to say something about
they said well go for it you know we'll
see what happens
and all hell broke loose and continues
to break loose for that matter which is
one of the things that's so bloody
strange about it is it doesn't seem to
end
and i would have thought when it first
started i thought oh well you know i'd
be a flash in the pan
for a week or something or two weeks or
a month or six months or a year or
two years or but it doesn't stop
and i really can't understand that it's
it's beyond my comprehension
now i guess it's partly because i
continue to communicate
my thoughts to some degree even talking
to
mainstream media people although
increasingly less and perhaps not at all
from here on in i mean i i had an
interview with the london times
two weeks ago three weeks ago it was
published and you know it was just
another
complete absolute bloody nightmare for
my family
my daughter in particular because they
took her to task in an
extraordinarily nasty way and um you
know and the journalist who did the
interview was completely she
you couldn't invent her you know not
only the way she
she she was so deceitful in what she did
but
i i learned more about her background
afterward as a consequence of another
journalist who wrote about her and
you know she's um a very
singular person to say the least and
so i did feel at the time like you did i
guess that
i was more afraid of not speaking than i
was afraid of speaking
and i have something against being told
what to say it's like
i'll pay the price for what i have to
say
i'm not going to pay the price to say
what you want me to say
you go say it yourself and see what the
hell happens
and you know maybe that's just a kind of
incomprehensible stubbornness in some
sense
um although i did i think i did
see what has i did see the beginnings of
what has unfolded since then
although i can't even really put my
finger on what it is that's happening
so well i i wonder a little bit about um
you know in some ways you know there's
nothing good about why you were absent
from the scene
uh but there may be something good
about your having not been there for
every moment of it and being able to
come back to the discussion
with something like fresh eyes because a
lot of this is
developmental and you know you say
you're surprised that um
that this is continuing and i must say
i'm having the same experience i feel
like i was
picked up you know my whole family was
picked up by a tornado and we haven't
been put down and you know i sort of
feel like
we were joined in the tornado during
it was such a crazy year that a lot of
people whose lives were continuing in
some
normal fashion are suddenly aware that
things are
wildly off-kilter um but actually this
this raises a question
i think one of the things that i know
from my own life
and you know i know of course
a bit about your life because of the
fact that it's public and because
i've met tammy and and have had a chance
to
to interact with you in that context as
well
but the the question i have
is
i wonder about the difference
between a person who might think the way
you or i would think
about um bad policy
and you know compelled speech and that
sort of thing
the difference between a person who
might think such a thing in isolation
and a person who has a proper familial
context in which to actually check in
so in other words i have the sense that
in part the reason
that i'm able to just simply describe
things as they are and
do so unflinchingly is because
my family understands the same puzzle
and they may have different
elements that they see with clarity but
there's no question i can you know i can
go to heather and i can say
you know i ran into this thing today and
here's what i'm concerned it implies and
we can have
a rational discussion about it without
anybody accusing anybody of
moral defects or any of the things that
have become so common
and so in your case i know that you have
a familial network that provides you
that same
kind of reality check and then i wonder
looking
at the the generation of people
advancing
the woke revolution and i see the
failure of that very thing
and i can't help but wonder if it isn't
connected in other words the idea
that um that pair bonding that marrying
and producing a family has become
something that most people don't even
consider an essential part of
life it's not the objective of the
exercise it's a choice that some people
make at best
that that has left people very isolated
from any reality check which makes them
very vulnerable
when they are threatened with an
accusation like
you're a racist you're a transphobe that
sort of thing
now you definitely need in this book
this is my new book by the way
and so it's coming out march 2nd and i
sort of clung to this like a life
raft over the last couple of years while
i was writing it there's a section in
here about sanity
you know and it's a critique to some
degree of psychoanalytic thought because
the psycho
not that i admire the psychoanalysts
tremendously but
they tended to think of sanity as
something that was organized inside your
psyche or let's say
inside your brain for that matter or
maybe even a reflection of healthy brain
function
but sanity is to large part outsourced
and what i mean by that is that
if you're fortunate and you're well
socialized
um other people find you acceptable
enough to include you in their
networks and then all you have to do is
pay attention to
the functioning of that network and
regulate your behavior
as a consequence of the feedback you
receive and you more or less stay
sane and so like if you have a family
and you have
friends then they'll help you make sure
that your jokes are funny and not
mean because they'll laugh when they're
funny and they'll raise an eyebrow when
they're mean and then you can check in
with that and
they'll help you figure out if you're
dominating the conversation too much and
they'll
they'll push and prod you as you do the
same to them
and everyone stays relatively organized
and when all this hit to begin with
i had quite a large network of people
which expanded at some point to include
people like you and
the so-called intellectual dark web
members and they were helping me
check in on my sanity all the time you
know
helping guiding me guide me through the
interview process of
analyzing my errors and commenting when
i did something
hypothetically right and and my family
played an integral role in that and so
that was extremely helpful i never
thought about that
as a precondition for for uh
saying what i said but i think there's
something about that that's right it's
certainly the case that
like i have tremendously supportive
parents still they're both still alive
they're still tremendously supportive at
a very deep deep level and i think that
that was a real gift that i had that
many people don't have
you know i've been struck one of the
things that torments me
constantly is and i think it's really
hurt me to discover this
is i had no idea how
deep the desperation was
for people who lack encouragement
it's just because every time i
talk about this it makes me tear up
because of what i've seen
i think but all these people that i've
met now
you know i spoke when i went on my book
tour
which was an unbelievable event
unbelievably positive event but also i
would even say to somebody
traumatic traumatically positive like it
was just too much
i really loved it but
to see the depth of hunger that people
had for
an encouraging word was unbelievably
tragic and for people to come up to me
repeatedly over and over and over
hundreds maybe thousands of times and
say you know i was in such
desperate straits looking for some
encouragement
unable to find it and then you know i
came across your lectures i thought
jesus it's pretty thin gruel to feed
a starving population i mean i'm
absolutely pleased beyond belief that
people have found
what i've done useful but
that doesn't uh decrease the impact of
the realization of just
how hurt how much hurt there is
and i and it is hurt this ground in a
lack of encouragement i have that i've
been encouraged my whole life
so man that could easily be part of what
now you know i also thought somewhat
calculate
in a calculated way about this like
and i don't know how far this goes back
but i've i also organized my life so
that i was standing
i had legs out in many directions i had
a clinical practice i had a business i
had my
professorship i had my writing you know
i had multiple sources of income
pretty independent areas and so i and i
did that in part to maximize
my capacity for freedom i thought well
and this wasn't something i think i
thought explicitly you know it was
part of what unfolded in my life across
time
it wasn't easy to take me out although
i've been taken out a lot
like far more than i thought
might be possible um i can't separate
that exactly from
intrinsic health problems you know but
i i despite my you know i don't have i
it isn't obvious to me that i can go
back to the university
i'm still employed there i'm on leave
they would take me back
i don't know if i can do it um
i don't have my clinical practice
anymore which i really miss i love doing
that and that was 20 hours a week you
know i
so that's a lot of time i finished
writing this book but i'm not writing
right now
and so a lot of i don't have any
pressing financial concerns and so
that's
that of course that's a huge privilege a
huge benefit
and thank god for that but
despite me being distributed like that i
was still
taken out pretty hard
so yes uh well you you know
i i confess
i have wondered while you were um
[Music]
incommunicado over the last year whether
that was just
um goliath's good fortune or if there
might be something more to it
because you were such a singular voice
at the point
that tammy got sick and then you did
that um obviously it was a tremendous
blow to those of us in
intellectual dark web space in our
ability
to uh to fight and to hold the line
um but you clearly have been taken out
in your words
um deliberately multiple times and you
know how it comes
about i don't know it's it's my it's
amazing to me that it continues to
happen
and the thing the thing that's so damn
weird is that exactly the same thing
continues to happen you know and it was
just replayed with this times article
now i have thought i had a lot of
interviews lined up
for this book and
once the times article came out my i
reacted to it my family reacted to it
and we
we dealt with it effectively the same
thing happened
that had happened to me before when
journalists had written a hit piece
about me it was
extremely stressful because when it
happens you do not
know which way it's going to go and you
know you can get unlucky
and a number of bad things can happen to
you simultaneously
all that has to happen is for that to
happen once to exceed your
capacity to deal with the number of bad
things and you're out that's basically
an accident i really think that's what's
hap what happened to me
in the last few years is that everything
that happened socially was
unbelievably stressful positive and
negative
you know the positive end of it was
extremely intense
and and and amazingly compelling and
interesting but the negative end was
really
really stressful you know and i notice
what happens to people
generally speaking and i don't think i'm
making this up is
you know i've watched the typical person
who gets mobbed on twitter
will get mobbed by 20 people and it'll
last for two or three days and they'll
apologize like mad they're so stressed
out they retreat right away
and it's really hard on them you know
and that happened to me
like i don't know how many times 100
times
200 times and really publicly
uh you know i've been called every
bloody name in the book and that's been
really literally i mean i remember one
day where i was called a jewish shill in
a nazi the same day you know by two
competing publications
and i thought maybe they canceled each
other out you know
but but and that's been very hard on my
family you know and and
and although they they're doing
reasonably well
under the circumstances but then you
know tammy got sick
terribly and and in a really nasty way
and then
her when her surgery was
complications multiplied and she was
near death
daily for months and then this
proclivity i had for depression
seemed to have become untreatable and
that took me out and so and i'm still
struggling with that you know i get up
i can hardly stand up when i wake up in
the morning i i feel so bad i can't
believe i can be alive and feel that bad
i stumble downstairs and i'm in the
sauna for about an hour and a half
and then i can stand up long enough to
have a shower
which i do for about 20 minutes and i
scrub myself from top to bottom trying
to
wake up and then i can more or less get
upstairs
and i eat and then i go for i walk like
10 miles every day
because i need to do that in order to
deal with this whatever it is that's
plaguing me and
i can get myself to the point where by
this time in the afternoon i'm more or
less functional
but then it repeats the next day and so
and it's oh my god that's terrible
it is it's terrible it's it's it's so
terrible
it's so terrible that i can't think
about it without it being traumatic
so i i have a hard time figuring out
where to place my mind because this has
been happening it's been happening every
day really
for for two years i think it's fair to
say that every single day of the last
two years has been worse
than any day i had previous to that
oh my goodness and what a predicament
you're in then because
um you know i can hear i would guess it
anyway knowing
knowing you and knowing of you in the
way that i do
but you're caught in this predicament
where that's really
intolerable and frankly most people
wouldn't tolerate it
but you also know that there is you know
both at the level of your family
and at the level of those who admire you
and listen to you
and uh are you know waiting to hear
the little bits of affirmation that they
need the little bits of guidance
that they were unable to get in the
world you know
how much good comes from your facing
that uh what sounds like a completely
excruciating
um existence yes but it's perverse
beyond comprehensibility which is sort
of the hallmark of a traumatizing
experience
because it is exactly that and i like i
look at it
and i can't get my i can't wrap my mind
around it
it well i and also that
the uh the my degree of exposure
you know when i when i decided to make
those videos i was playing with youtube
and i was playing with fire like youtube
is fire
in a way social media is fire in a way
that is
ver unimaginable it's so powerful
youtube will see but youtube
demolishes the printing press in terms
of
of its long-term significance i mean
because now
we can now you can do with video and
audio what you did with print and it's
way easier
you have access to a massive audience
with no intermediaries whatsoever
and you know i and i i don't know really
how to grapple with that either
how to comprehend it well
i mean actually this brings me to one of
the things i've been
hoping to talk to you about for the
longest time
so i think there's a part of you that
finds
um you've always been very gracious
about it and
and welcoming but finds my liberalism
a bit paradoxical no no i don't look
look i don't i understand
the catastrophe of the pareto
distribution
i don't like it you know it it there is
this proclivity
for capital to accrue in the hands of
smaller and smaller numbers of people
it's just capital it's all goods
you get this terrible problem of
distribution that it's like a natural
law
and the fact that people object to that
is completely unsurprising and the fact
that if it goes unchecked it destroys
societies is that i don't think that's a
hypothesis that's
demonstrably self-evident um
so i don't find
i especially don't find the concern the
compassionate concern
for for working class people and their
well-being
the least bit incomprehensible it's the
solutions that are the problem
it's like well what should the solutions
be and well that's
that's where things get very very
complicated it's not
well perfect and i i'm sorry if i
implied
something that wasn't wasn't even my
perception
i think you are to an extent
a conservative but i find you uh if i
listen to you
it's not a simple kind of conservative
i'm a conservative for the same reason
you are
you already pointed out like if you're a
social scientist
and you don't understand the law of
unintended consequences
you are not a very good social scientist
i learned from my
my clinical research and from studying
clinical research for so long and
publishing it too
is that you think your intervention is
going to do what you think it's going to
do
but it isn't it's going to do something
else and
you you have to build in if
you if you have a an intervention that
you think is going to have beneficial
results
you have to build in an assessment to
see if it has those results and
like i talked to the woman who headed
the um
the name of the was done in not in
cambridge but in
in massachusetts it was a longitudinal
study of anti-social children the first
longitudinal study it was done in a
working-class neighborhood just outside
of cambridge
i used to live there and i can't
remember the name at the moment but in
any case
this team intervened with kids that were
likely to have a
uh they came for broken homes broken
neighborhoods anti-social neighborhoods
this was done
in the 1930s and they intervened at the
level of the child and at the level of
the teachers and at the level of the
parents and
ran this multiple year project to reduce
risk for
negative outcomes among this population
randomly assigned
uh participants to groups and
by all accounts from the participants
the children the parents the teachers
and the
professionals who were running the
investigation
it was a resounding success they looked
at the results and the
intervention group did worse on
virtually every outcome measure
and they figured out later that the
reason for that likely was that they
took the antisocial kids and grouped
them together in summer camp
they took them out of the city to put
them in camp they thought that would be
a good intervention
but grouping them together seemed to
produce a competition for anti-social
behavior and
it overwhelmed all of the other
interventions
that was joan mccord famous study and i
talked to joan
mccord a lot about that and but you see
that all over the intervention
literatures
it's very hard to fix it's very hard to
define a problem correctly
it's very hard to define in to develop
an intervention
that's that addresses that problem and
only that problem and then it's very
hard to get the intervention to do what
you want it to and that's what makes
me conservative to the degree that i am
so yep no i think that's that's
incredibly wise i would add one thing to
your list it's not just
that it's hard to get an intervention to
do what you want it to do
it is that it is hard to get it to do
what you want it to do
and at scale these things also tend to
evolve so even
if you did manage to solve right and so
the the problem of unintended
consequences
coupled with the problem of perverse
incentives and therefore bad policy that
is effectively corruption
is a very frightening problem and so i
do think we are
caught in a basically damned if you do
damned if you don't
scenario we can't stay here and you know
you're
i agree with you the um social media for
lack of a
uh a better term for it is
going to dwarf the printing press for
various reasons some of them because
it's so easy yeah but also because it's
of a fundamentally different nature
right when you're reading a book it may
be that somebody
writes something that's bad for you to
absorb
but you know you're reading a book
because the experience of it the
uh the perception of it is of a book
whereas
um social media increasingly fools the
mind
into you know the interaction you and i
are having is more or less a
face-to-face interaction
but a lot of interactions that look like
face-to-face interactions
don't have these characteristics and at
best the impact on the mind is arbitrary
so you know we're watching things like
amplifiers of threat and you know this
goes back to the thing we were
discussing earlier
with twitter for here's a good example
of unintended consequences it's like
what don't we know
okay we don't know what regulates human
communication
we know that if you restrict the
bandwidth people don't understand each
other as well
but we don't know how communication
functions it's too complicated okay so
we
absolutely don't know what happens to
communication
at a large scale when you restrict
people to 140 or 280 characters and then
put them in a network of millions of
other people
we have no idea and it could be that you
you tremendously bias the discourse
towards impulsive anger
it looks like that if you look at
twitter i mean and
because it's a 140 or 280 characters you
can whip something off very quickly and
so it's almost as if the technology is
implicitly commanding you to be
impulsively aggressive and then we don't
know what it means when
only those people who are motivated to
be impulsively aggressive that day are
those that are communicating and then
when you only see those communications
even though
you know 10 000 people might read your
tweet only
100 who are irritated for some reason
respond
we don't know any of that and and
we completely underestimate the power of
the technology because it looks harmless
it just sits there on your phone and
doesn't do anything and so you know
god only knows what kind of tower of
babel that is
so right and not only that but um
the fact that the algorithm changes and
we don't get any notice of it not only
do we not have access
to whatever the algorithm's content is
but we don't know when it changes which
means it's impossible for us to even
track the impact of our own behavior
because we can't run a controlled
experiment it's like predicting the
stock market
it's an illusion that you're dealing
with the same thing every day
it's complete and then of course we
don't know
you know the algorithms increasingly
have a life of their own and
increasingly they're governed by
artificial intelligence and
and it it builds in it builds in
it derives implications that we don't
even understand and
and as you pointed out it all changes so
quickly that we can't keep up with it in
any
event so yes so
right so so then the the conversation
and i'm i'm certain it's going to take
uh
multiple tries for us to get there uh
hopefully
we'll have the opportunity for multiple
discussions but
the question is all right you're a
conservative
but you're a wise conservative that
understands the importance of liberalism
understands the necessity of tension
between the desire
not to mess things up with unintended
consequences and the desire to solve
problems that are actually solvable and
i would argue
the necessity to solve certain problems
which will be fatal if we don't solve
them
um but the the combination
in other words i think there's a new
dialogue that has to happen those
conservatives who understand the puzzle
need to get together with those liberals
who understand the puzzle
and figure out what the new insights are
because we are somewhere
so novel that if there's one thing we
can say
it's that our system is unstable and it
is putting us in
great jeopardy which means that even if
your impulses are
conservative and you point out correctly
that i have some
conservative impulses even if your
impulses are conservative
um we aren't anywhere right we're
uh we're on a precipice in a windstorm
and at some level we have to make enough
progress
relative to the fundamental instability
of the system and the fundamental
you know here let me take an example
the point you make about social media
and the human psyche you could make
exactly the same point
about pharmaceuticals and physiology
that we know very little about the way
the body actually works
yeah i could sure make that case all
right yeah
i'll i'll bet you can the the hell
you've been through
makes this point very clearly but you
know i'm
constantly struck by the fact that our
narrative
about medicine proceeds from an entirely
false premise
which is that we know a great deal about
the body and have all of these useful
interventions
what we have is a lot of interventions
where sometimes we know
what one of their effects is we very
rarely
understand why the spectrum of uh
you know collateral consequences are
what they are and all of these systems
are linked together
and nobody is tracking the long-term
implications of anything so we
we have this sort of obsessive focus on
the things that you can detect on very
short time scales
and almost a studied ignorance of what
the same pharmaceuticals or procedures
do to us long term right and we then
i suspect if you did the statistics
properly i suspect that
that medicine independent of public
health kills more people than it saves
i suspect if you if you factor in
phenomena
like the development of superbugs in
hospitals for example
that overall the net consequence of
hospitals is negative
now that's just a guess and but it's and
and it could easily be wrong
but it it also could not be wrong and
that is a good example or that's where
my thinking about what we don't know has
taken me
with regards to the critique of what we
do
the fact that it's even plausible is a
stunning well you know medical error is
the third leading cause of death
yeah you know and that doesn't take into
account
the generation of superbugs for example
the generation of superbugs or you know
if you're thinking broadly about it
let's i i don't know where you stand on
this issue but i have been
tracking the lab leak hypothesis
for covid and it is very distressing to
me
that as much as it's an unsettled
question
the evidence for the lab leak gets
stronger over time
all of the competing hypotheses fall one
by one
and are replaced by some alternative
that hasn't yet been falsified
but that's very ominous to me and if
this is the case
if this was a bug that was modified
in the lab through gain of function
research and escaped
then you have to add that to
the balance sheet with respect to the
costs of medical errors because
it looks like if this was an escapee
from the wuhan lab that it was an
escapee from experiments designed
to create a vaccine to protect us from
future coronaviruses
so we can't say that with specificity
but if we look at the circumstantial
evidence of what was being studied how
it was being studied and what the likely
purpose of those
investigations were then this is
you know the mother of all
self-inflicted wounds
and it is uh downstream
of naive thinking about the cost-benefit
ratio
of enhancing the infectivity
of uh viruses
i know i did know that that that's
something that you've been tracking and
pursuing
i don't have an opinion about it because
i don't know enough about it to have an
opinion
um so i'd also
with regards to conservatism you know
i don't know if approaching
how people should deal with the problems
in their lives from a psychological
perspective
the viewpoint of a clinical psychologist
i wonder if that kind of
automatically makes you conservative in
some way because my locus of concern has
always been the
individual and so and an individual
well-being and
you know being trained as a behavioral
psychologist
i always took as my unit of analysis the
enhancement of well-being
of health let's say at the individual
level and maybe translated into
political and when that's translated
into the political landscape maybe that
looks something
like conservatism i don't know i mean i
never thought about this
i never thought about what i was doing
in political terms to begin with like
even my initial statement about bill
c-16 in compelled speech wasn't
supposed to be something specifically
political i just thought the political
had escaped its boundaries it's like
no you don't get to infringe on free
speech you're no longer in the political
realm at that point that's a different
realm get the hell back where you belong
that's how it looked to me but you know
the everything that's another thing
that's very peculiar about our culture
at the moment it's almost impossible to
have a discussion about anything
and have the coverage not be politicized
and i think that's partly a function of
how the media the
the legacy media worked because they
tended to view everything through a
political lens
and also a consequence of this
insistence and this i think comes
primarily from the radical left that
everything is political and i don't buy
that it's like
you can say that everything has a
political aspect
but that's a completely different claim
than everything is political which is a
totalizing claim and i also as a social
scientist don't like totalizing claims
because most things are multivariate
complex
and so well so
yeah i think we can prove that
um you can politicize everything
but not everything is political and that
the tendency to view
everything in political terms destroys
our ability
to properly navigate questions on which
we actually ought to have
alignment and this is uh it's a very
disturbing
pattern to see um every
question including uh covet itself
turned into a team sport because that is
of course
sabotaging exactly the ability to reason
through
our various options and then to get us
to move in a coordinated direction
to actually address the
uh the pandemic and in some sense
i suspect we are headed to
um having to accept covet as a permanent
fact
of the landscape when that was not
a foregone conclusion that in effect our
politicizing of this issue
is going to leave us with a bug that we
can't ever get rid of
why do you think that like i mean i've
been hoping that
and watching israel in particular there
seems to be some indication that they've
got the vaccinations ramped up to the
point where
they're having some effect on the rate
of transmission of the virus which is a
positive thing and
you know i keep hoping that the vaccines
are there's enough of them and they're
getting out there fast enough so that we
might be able to
keep the bug under control you you're
not so optimistic about that
apparently no i'm not because for one
thing
i know that it's you know it's been
obvious from the beginning it was going
to evolve
and that the key to managing its
evolving
out of our control was limiting the
number of people
who had it and limiting their ability to
spread new variants around the globe
and we've done a terrible job of this
somehow you know a year in it is only
beginning to be uh it is only beginning
to dawn on us that new mutants
that are harder for our immune systems
to recognize
are essentially a certainty and
that the key to ever regaining control
is to ensure that when these things
arise somewhere they don't immediately
find their way
around the globe so i guess what i would
say
is i think
we tend to you know even the the idea of
compromise in a political sense
is the wrong approach with something
like covid we should have been
much more aggressive earlier on so that
our total
level of compromise with respect to
civil liberties
could have been much less in other words
if
early on we had engaged in
a really intense six-week lockdown and
we had
um ramped up our capacity
to test for covid with precision
so that after six weeks basically the
idea of six weeks would be
it's very hard to control covet inside
of a household it tends to bounce around
but that it will tend to burn itself out
in most households within
something like a six-week week period um
that if we had engaged in that and then
used
track and trace to find and control
outbreaks
following such an intense lockdown we
might not have had to deal with a full
year of the half-assed measure and the
sense is
the sense that i have is that we're
getting
you know uh maybe it's a pareto
distribution maybe it's we're
suffering 80 percent of the harm of
lockdowns and getting 20
of the value that we might get for
having you know
not gone the full distance and
um unfortunately
i think the prerequisite to our behaving
rationally
is having a um
having our experts completely
liberated from market forces from
political dynamics
and free to tell us what it is that we
need to know
and then getting on the same page and
having a proper
rubric for evaluating what has worked
and what hasn't
and instead what we've had is a
thoroughly politicized discussion from
the get-go
in which even our counter-measures are
uh
fought over on the basis of you know if
you
you know why is it that a you know a
trump voter is much more likely to be a
masked skeptic
a question of mask is an empirical
question it shouldn't have anything to
do with your
political leanings and yet it undeniably
does
uh in in north america and that has
has robbed us of the kinds of controls
that we might otherwise have instituted
i wanted to ask you we you
talked i want to bring the just
discussion if you don't mind back to
something that we were touching on
earlier that your initial objection when
you were at evergreen too
whatever it was that was developing in
the background
and now we've had four years to see
whatever it is
manifesting itself and so you what is it
what is it that's happening do you think
in our politicized landscape
i mean well um i have a guess and it's
it's right up your alley it's something
i i'm intending to explore
um at greater length but the basics
are this i suspect
you and i i think would share the
opinion
that um psychological development
is among the most important phenomena
for understanding human beings
and it is underrated we tend to look at
the behavior of adults
and study it but we should spend more
time thinking about how those adults
ended up the way they did in order to
really understand them and
i think for uh
you know for each generation
you have a developmental landscape and
what
the governing forces are in that
developmental landscape has a lot to say
about both the insights and the blind
spots
of the people who emerge from it and so
um i would say that
for americans of my generation i'm a gen
x the market played too much of a role
developmentally and it has created a
kind of
lens through which we can't help but
look
at his you know commodified things in a
way that is
quite unhealthy for you
i was born in 1969 okay
um for millennials and maybe even more
so for gen
z i suspect that there is
a pivot to something else and many
people
you know uh jonathan height and greg
lukianov have certainly talked about
igen the internet generation but
what i suspect is really going on is
that if you are
sufficiently plugged into the internet
early enough there comes a point at
which
the your
persona on the internet takes primacy
it is more important than your actual
physical
life jesus it's worse than that it's
worse than that
i would say from personal experience
there's more of me on the internet than
there is in me
my electronic avatars are
far more powerful than me
personally you know and i can watch this
because i've been away for a year and a
half
and yet my internet presence has
steadily
increased during that time and i i look
online now and it's
700 million views
something like so now now imagine that
as the developmental environment
for children now here's here's the
connection i want to draw
my contention is that the online
landscape
is postmodern right that if we were just
to simply describe it
the rules the physics of online life
are post-modern because it's extracted
from the environment
right so for example like living in a
dictionary if i
decided tomorrow that i was a woman
right i could change my
internet presence such that i would
present
in a female way i could
say hey anybody who doesn't treat me as
female is a jerk
and the point is i have transitioned
completely
right now obviously there's no such
thing
in the physical world you can transition
you can take
hormones or blockers you can get
surgeries
but no um no
man has ever become a woman and
reproduced
in a female way right
so the point is the physical world
has all kinds of constraints that come
from physics and biology
which do not translate to the online
world and for people like you and me for
whom the online world is an
add-on world we think well
obviously real life is the important one
and then the online thing has some
interface with it which is frightening
but we understand
how they relate but if you reverse these
two things
then what you get is a generation
that its problem-solving mind says
actually of course you can transition
you can transition
and then it is everybody's obligation to
live by who you've
told us you are and anybody who doesn't
is a bad person
and what has to be true for that to be
the case
right you know i had i had a fantasy a
long while ago that
people would end up wearing glasses like
the google glasses
that would be illegal to take off
and that you'd be mandated to see what
people wanted you to see
it was their right to be presented to
you
in the manner that they chose to present
themselves
you know and i'm not saying that's a
particularly brilliant vision but it's
very much in keeping with what you're
describing
boom yep i think it's i think it's close
but if you imagine then that
an online world in which effectively we
can all be equal tomorrow as long as
we say that that's the objective and we
can all present as we want
and others can be forced to adhere to it
or be thrown off of whatever discussion
then all of this begins to make a great
deal of sense and so i'm wondering if we
are not in effect
in a kind of civil war between
those for whom the real world has
primacy
and those for whom the online world has
primacy and if that's not the
fundamental nature of the battle
well i think it it could be the the
fundamental nature of a
part of the battle i mean part obviously
part of what's going on is whatever this
unbelievably rapid
rate of technological transformation is
doing to us i mean
my my daughter and and some people of
approximately her age so late 20s
are helping me with
manage social media let's say um
she's noticed that people five years
younger than her have advantages in
understanding the newly developed forms
of social media that she's already
outside
of and so that process of being hooked
into the web
and that being the determining factor
for your
world view is probably accelerating i
mean it's going to accelerate obviously
it's going to accelerate because the web
is becoming more and more dominant and
machines are becoming more and more
intelligent so they abstract themselves
away from the world
and then the question is well what's the
consequence of that abstraction
but it's funny that it's postmodern
that doesn't there's more
going on with whatever it is that's
happening
than than technological transformation
but you think that's the fundamental
driving factor
well i think there are a lot of ways you
can look at it obviously
i don't think this is a real battle
obviously
the internet runs on hardware in the
real world
and everybody you know when the power
goes out
we are all reduced to our biological
self so i don't think there is
actually anything to fight over one of
these worlds has primacy and the other
is an add-on and this is not debatable
but my point is really about the mental
confusion
that arises from for most people
i mean if you think about the lives that
most people are living
right most people at best are
working a job in which they trade
their labor for money that they get to
spend on
goods or relatively generic
adventures and the part of their life
that is
interesting and compelling is you know
the internet over which they range
freely and engage in
battle and you know they fall in love
increasingly and whatever else they do
and so
my point is that that is a distortion
developmentally
it misleads the mind into
misunderstanding
what is necessary if you take the
postmodern rules of the internet
and you now impose them on politics in
the real world
you get crises you get
the basic structure of civilization
coming apart in front of our eyes which
i really believe that it is
right with the homelessness crisis in
the u.s for example
is jaw-dropping and we have
a particularly acute crisis on the west
coast
in the u.s that appears to be the result
of people
being utterly compelled of
their own political beliefs to an extent
that even as those beliefs are
failing around them visibly they just
double down
so um imagining that people who think
the internet has primacy are now
exerting
a force to correct the real world in the
direction
of their naive internet understanding of
things
are in danger of
crashing the the aircraft
and in some sense people like you and me
are responding to what they're saying
about how we should restructure
the real world and saying that doesn't
make sense
it won't work it is going to put us in
grave danger
it is going to disrupt essential things
and
you know there are those who can hear us
and we are popular with those who can
hear us
and then there are those who regard
our uh pointing out the obvious as a
danger to their program who are
intent on silencing us and so i haven't
thought about this
obsession with identity from a
developmental perspective too
and i thought this insistence
by a uh loud minority
that their determination of their
identity take
primacy is first of all it's just
it's wrong technically i think because
an identity isn't merely what you feel
you are
an identity is way more complicated than
that as any decent social
constructionist should already know
an identity is a role
a set of complex roles that you
negotiate with other people
so that you can thrive across a very
long span of time
and it it can't be something that you
impose on other people because then they
won't cooperate
with you now you might say that you have
a right to impose certain
aspects of it on other people and you
could have a reasonable debate
about that but identity is definitely
not merely what you feel it is and it's
certainly not
merely what you feel it is moment to
moment
that identity is actually much more like
that of a three or four year old child
and i mean this technically it's not an
insult
so when you're a child you pick up one
identity after another and play with
them so for example my granddaughter
who's about three at the moment if you
ask her who she is she has two names
a first name and a second name and her
dad calls her by her second name and her
mom calls her by her first name so
she's ellie or scarlett and she's fine
with either of those
but she's also pocahontas and if you ask
her
whether she's ellie or scarlet or
pocahontas she will say pocahontas
and she has said that for eight months
it's amazing it's been that persistent
in a child of that age it's quite
remarkable but what she's doing
are is playing you know and girls will
play to be boys at that age and boys
will play to be girls and
they're they play with multitudinous
identities and then
they settle into one so then the
question is
what if you disrupt that play that's
fantasy play
and then another question might be well
what if you disrupt it with technology
not the technology itself is producing a
message that's counter to that
but that the fact that children are on
technology all the time
means they're not engaging in that kind
of identity establishing fantasy play
and then you might say well maybe what
you see happening in that case is that
it bursts out
in late adolescence and the insistence
there that my identity is what i say it
is is actually the
the scream in some sense of a of an
organism that
hasn't gone through that egocentric
period of play where they are in in a
fictional sense exactly the way they
define themselves
you can't tell my granddaughter who's
three that she isn't pocahontas
it's stupid to tell her that because she
means it in an experimental sense
and all you're doing is interfering with
her fantasy play and so i see a fair bit
of this as
delayed fantasy play with the kind of
pathology that comes up when you delay a
necessary
developmental stage now that could be
wrong you know when probably is
but but still it looks to me like
it looks to me like that's part of
what's happening
it's very strange to see this insistence
like i just it's so conceptually
unsophisticated the
the even the hypothesis that identity is
only what you feel that it is and
the intense insistence that that be the
case is also another mystery it's like
why is it that it's a foregone
conclusion that other people have to go
along with your self-definition
so i think uh first of all that's
fascinating and that fits
rather exactly with what i'm getting at
and i suspect it is adding
a dimension where i was vague about the
developmental
pathway but you're absolutely right that
a child
can take on an identity and effectively
within limits they are allowed to assert
that identity and adults will play along
with it encouraging and right
now the thing is there's a process i'm
more familiar with the
you know the male side of this because i
you know i went through boyhood and and
being a young man but
if you have a misunderstanding
about how you present in the world so
you assert that you are one way
then your peers will you know if your
peers are nice
they will poke fun at you in order to
reveal to you what it is that you
actually present as
so that you can adjust your self image
right and that's part of that's part of
healthy socialization like that's what
happens
that's it once you pull out of that
egocentric stage
where you're playing with yourself then
you have to integrate other people into
your play and then it's a
then it's a negotiation otherwise you're
not accepted by your peers
and so that's another thing that's very
interesting is that it is precisely
those
children who aren't accepted by their
peers that insist
that their self-definitions rule
and then the what one of the things
that's kind of terrifying about that is
if you know the child anti-social
literature
there's a there's a percentage of
children that are quite aggressive
at the age of two almost all of them are
male
almost all of them are socialized out of
their regression by the time they're
four
the the percentage that isn't become
persistent lifetime offenders
if they're not if their behavior isn't
rectified by the time they're for which
means
if they're not transformed into children
that are acceptable to their
peers there's no intervention that is
being evident in the literature that
will reverse that
so uh i i this is
this is both frightening and it's making
me happy in the sense that
uh i believe that the model that we are
wrestling to the surface here
is um accurate and it doesn't fit what
most people are expecting is going on
and i i think there's a lot of power in
understanding it this way but
what you are effectively saying is that
there's a period in which
self-definition is identity in some
sense
and then there is a period of correction
at which your
uh insistence on who you are meets
everyone's else's insistence on who you
are
and you then learn who you actually are
and
that thing better be a pretty good match
for the world but then yeah
it better be all right right and so i i
have argued as
an evolutionist that the i would say the
uh the job of a parent is to mirror
the environment that the child will
mature into
so that when they get there they have
the software that is an appropriate
match for it and a lot of
uh mental health issues come down to a
mismatch
between the software that your
developmental environment produced and
the environment you actually live in and
that can happen
why you shouldn't be nicer to your
children than the world is
in fact you're doing them a disservice
that's the devouring mother from the
psychoanalytic perspective
right and this gets into some very
uncomfortable territory what you know
what does good if you're a slave if
you're born into slavery
and you produce children how should you
parent them
should you protect them from well i
would say all of the implications of
slavery
let's go through the stage idea again
because there's three stages i think
there's
there's the the egocentric stage where
the child is
manifesting multiple identities
self-defined and playing
then and that's under the protection of
parents the parents put
up a walled enclosure so to speak
within which the child can do that
experimentation then the child
meets the world of peers that happens
between the ages of four and the ages of
17 18 something like that and that's
when your
identity has to uh expand to include
others in a cooperative and negotiated
way
you have to manage competition and
cooperation
and your identity becomes socialized
and then there's a stage beyond that i
would say where you kind of pop out of
that socialization and you're no longer
necessarily a member of the group
it's like a self-actualized person that
although i don't like that phrase
the self-actualization theorists thought
to some degree in this manner once
you're done with your apprenticeship
you can become post-apprentice and then
you can
take control of your own destiny to some
degree independently of your peers
so hopefully you can get to there but
and so that's part of the answer to the
slavery
um conundrum you know you should be a
good member of your group but you
shouldn't only be that
well i think there are two different
questions the the slavery issue
is the very uncomfortable idea that if a
parent
is supposed to mirror the adult
environment that a child will have to
get along in
then a person whose children will mature
into an arbitrary environment needs to
understand that it's an arbitrary
environment rather than being protected
from it right in order to you know to
properly
avoid running a foul of the arbitrary
authorities in a slave environment
one has to be developmentally brought
into how you navigate below the radar
how you you know how you play that game
and so anyway you would expect the
parenting to look very different and
you know this idea that childhood is you
know
a joyous time where you should be free
of all of those adult influences is
exactly wrong it's prep
it's preparation so um
though now if we take this model that i
think you and i are
agreeing on here about the fact that the
and i i like your point here um
that there are three stages you've got i
assert my
identity independent of the world then
the world and i negotiate over what my
actual identity is
and then i'm not an apprentice anymore
and i get to be who i am in the adult
world having been informed by that
process
and you imagine that you've got
generations now
one and a half of them maybe for whom
the online environment was so compelling
and so much the source of most of their
affirmation
that its rules have become sacrosanct to
them
and those rules really do look like
you know they're it's a it's a childish
world right you join
some community of people you tell them
who you are
there are rules about them having to
respect who you've told them you know it
is
if i say i'm pocahontas who are you to
say i'm not right
and um that
in some ways the answer to that question
in the real world is
i'm someone you have to get along with
in repeated interactions
but that may not be the case at all
online
that constraints you can just pick up
and move to the next community
and that's another thing we should talk
about because another thing that's
happening online
is that i've i've detected this
recently is that the online environment
is also making everyone acutely paranoid
and i think the reason for that is that
everyone
it it's easy for our thinking to go to
to go astray
and as we talked about earlier in this
discussion
other people tap you back into shape
and you're you're surrounded by a kind
of random assortment of other people in
the real world because you didn't select
them
so because it's random it's it provides
you with
what is in essence relatively unbiased
feedback
information but online you can choose
your
your compatriots and it's likely to be
the case that
at your weakest point psychologically
you choose the least
demanding compatriots and so your
craziest ideas are the least likely to
be challenged
all right so there's so many interesting
threads here
one of them i i my guess is you and i
will fall out in the same place here but
if you give me a choice between a
community
that uh believes everything i believe
and one in which people believe very
different things
i'm not going to choose the one in which
people believe the things i believe
because for one thing
it's the end of growth and it's deathly
i want to object slightly
okay i've had and you've had this
experience too
i've had the experience of being in an
environment where a very large number of
people don't agree with me vociferously
and what i would say is a little of that
goes a long way
even if you're a courageous thinker i'm
not going to put myself in that category
but
if even even if you're someone who wants
to be able to tolerate
dissent there's a limited amount of
dissent that you actually can tolerate
you
are going to seek out an environment
where most people agree with you
but some people don't some of the time
and it's kind of like listening to music
you'll like music that's optimally
different from what you
are enjoying right now right if it's
exactly the same it's boring if it's too
different you can't hear it
there's a there's a there's an amount of
novelty that you can tolerate but it's
not that
large and so even people who have been
trained
to look for evidence that disproves
their own theories they're only going to
be able to tolerate a tiny bit of that
at a time
it's too destabilizing it's too
destabilizing
well all right so i want to link this
back up to what you said
uh before about the three stages yeah um
so my experience
as a scientist is that
my most valuable characteristic
is the ability to compete to be
completely indifferent
to the prevailing wisdom on a given
point
right and i think this is no personal
stake in it
well i may even have a personal stake i
may come up with an
idea that compels me that it's probably
right a hypothesis
and i may advance it and have every
single one of my peers
say that's garbage and my sense is not
one of oh crap
i've said something bad my sense is well
wouldn't that be delightful
if i'm as right as i think i am then the
fact that everybody else doesn't get
this makes it even
even better right um so
my point is that's not normal i know
that's not normal and it's not normal
for
evolutionary reasons that are easy to
understand it takes a lot of training to
accomplish that
yes or a developmental environment that
rewards it
right sure if you have if you have the
right experience but then again you know
you said yourself remember
again at the beginning of this
conversation think about the
preconditions for that
is that in order to open yourself up to
that sort of criticism
you have to be supported in all sorts of
ways you know and even
so when i'm functioning as a scientist i
am trying to
disprove my presuppositions
you know i'll test them it's like some
something manifests itself in an
experiment then i designed three or four
experiments to see if i can make that
effect go away and i do that because i
don't want to propagate nonsense and i
don't want to pursue nonsense in my own
career
but in order to tolerate that think
about how we set up the system is
you have to be a tenured professor to do
science
or have the equivalent position in the
research lab but
your economic situation is stabilized
your social status is stabilized like
you're protected on 50 fronts and then
you can open the door and say okay
let's have some novelty come my way and
and and that that's assuming that you're
at a point where you can tolerate any
novelty at all
you know and more curious more open more
emotionally stable more intelligent
people
are more compelled by novelty and can
handle it better but still
our our ability our ability to handle it
is pretty low and we will find
environments that mostly
um reflect back to us what we want most
most uh comforting
well actually this is this is
fascinating
i wonder if there's not effectively
a budget for um
discordant interactions and
you know if we go back to what we were
speaking about it at the beginning of
the conversation
the fact that um not only do heather and
i have a great relationship but we also
speak the same
language scientifically so you know it's
a kind of across-the-board
um sounding board and uh ability to
you know i feel no vulnerability there
because there's no place where our world
views aren't compatible
and uh you know i could say similar
things about
about eric so what that means is that my
budget
for discordant interaction
is probably larger when i get to
the outside world
because i haven't spent it at home or in
the context of family or friends
and you know you spend that it is
definitely a budgetary phenomenon you
spend
like you produce a unit of
psychophysiological preparation for
every unit of uncertainty and
the the size of that unit of expenditure
varies
with your trade neuroticism because
that's like evolution's guess at how
dangerous the environment would be
it varies with your position in this in
the daw in the
in the social hierarchy because if
you're at the top where you're protected
the consequence of an error is
attenuated compared to what it would be
at the bottom
and that's why social position modulates
serotonergic output
so the higher you are in the hierarchy
the more serotonin dampens your negative
emotion to uncertain events
and that's in keeping with your with
your actual fragility neuroticism
determines it
social hierarchy determines it
intelligence determines it to some
degree because
you're a more effective problem solver
if you have a high iq
so but you do pay for uncertainty
because
if something's uncertain you don't know
what to do and so you have to prepare to
do everything
and that's unbelievably costly
psychophysiologically
it ramps your cortisol production up and
it it starts to eat away from future
reserves
it's definitely a budgetary process
so yep
um all right so i wanna i wanna see if
there's something
more um with respect to this model
in which four people whose developmental
environment has been uh
internet first and who have
wrongly encoded the lesson that my
identity is mine
to define and that those who would
challenge it
are enemies rather than people doing me
a favor of giving me information
i don't have about myself they are
enemies to be
challenged and driven out
then this interfaces with those of us
for whom the internet is not
our primary developmental
experience in the following way and i'm
using the
the case of trans ideology
simply because it's the clearest case
biologically
but if you take the rules
of trans and i actually believe probably
these ought to be the rules
online which is you can present
as whatever you want and by and large
people should just simply
treat you that way and you also by the
way online have the tools to do that
so that you're not creating uh
some kind of unresolvable paradox
but if we then say okay the online rules
are that there's no such thing as sex
because
a man can become a woman simply by
uh showing up as one and then we say
whatever must be true
in the real world in order for those
rules to be the rules everywhere
we are going to make those things true
therefore
it must be the case that biology was
wrong about sex and what's more
that because simply saying that
you are female
is sufficient to put you fully in that
category
then therefore whatever
morphology and physiology you happen to
have at the point that you make that
assertion
is consistent with being female and we
have the absurd discussion
that we now see so regularly about um
basically you know female penises and
things like this
and so those of us with real world
primacy
are constantly saying you can't rewrite
the rules of civilization
around simple claims in isolation like
all you have to do to be female is say
that that's what you are
and that that battle is one that is now
ironically
going to be lost in the real world
as a result of the fact that actually
political power
is accumulating in the hands of those
who subscribe to the online rules
so the the the identity issue is
i mean it forces us to to
one of the things i found so so
challenging about all of this is that
these challenges to fundamental
assumptions
force you to make arguments for things
you actually don't know how to argue for
so for example what does it mean to be
female
well i don't know because no one's
actually ever asked me that question
they just
act being female and i act be male
whatever that means and
we don't ever sit down and lay out the
explicit assumptions now
you do that to some degree when you're
arguing with your wife about
who's going to do what when and maybe
with your mother and when with your
sister you have local discussions when
when roles come into conflict but you
never
list the axioms that you're using to do
your perceptual categorization
and so then when you're forced to defend
your presumption you don't know how to
do it because you don't have the
arguments at hand
so to be female i mean
means something like and i'm
what do you do i had a discussion with
one of my
students former students today we're
trying to
help people develop this we're trying to
develop this program that helps people
um identify and then accomplish
important life tasks and
it's forced me to think about something
i've thought about over years
what are the important life tasks like
okay so
you should get educated to the
to the approximate level of your
intelligence
you should be employed gainfully have a
job or maybe if you're lucky a career
um you need an intimate relationship you
should have some friends you need a
family you need to regulate
the world of temptation drug and alcohol
use that sort of thing you have to take
care of your health
you need to make some use productive use
of your time outside of work
so there's eight things maybe there's
more but that's sort of eight
and maybe you don't need to be fully
accomplished along all of those eight
but they're pretty important and
they're not a bad start and if you can
come up with a better list
more power to you but well let's take
one you
can have a family an intimate
relationship and a family well the
classical way of doing that is that
someone's male and someone's female and
they get together and they have
children and then they have
grandchildren and that's like
a third of your life or a quarter of
your life or a fifth of your life i
don't care
it's some non-trivial portion of your
life and that identity
male and female is a precondition to
that root through life and then you have
children and they mean
something to you and they give you
something to do and you have
grandchildren and it's the same thing
so by playing out male and female it's
sort of like you've now
occupied 25 of your time productively
that's the role okay let's say we blow
that apart
well then what what are we supposed to
do then because
you can't pretend that into existence
and that's that's the post-modern
element of this this is the refusal of
the real world it's like
okay we'll make identity entirely
mutable but what are what
the the trans kids that came after me
in in in the first demonstration against
me
i i said you think i'm your enemy but
i'm not
and the reason i said that being a
clinician was because i thought well
you're adopting an identity
that that there is no rules for
what the hell are you going to do with
that you're
you're you're inviting so much trouble
into your life you can't even
possibly imagine it because you won't
know what to do
and people won't know how to treat you
and so where does that leave you
now you might say well i'm so distraught
about my
the discordance between my psychological
state my biological reality that
that pales in comparison and maybe there
are situations where that's the case but
man an identity
that doesn't solve the problem of how
you're going to live
isn't an identity i don't know what it
is
but it's not an identity yep
and i don't even know how people would
change the rules exactly
to make that work
so i i agree with you wholeheartedly
that um effectively
our identities are means to an end
and there is there are conservation laws
that apply
to the system as a whole and
unfortunately and this is actually
uh essentially the the core
argument of the book that heather and i
uh have just completed
but the core argument is
we are living in a period of
evolutionary hyper novelty
where human beings are actually the
species
for which uh we have the best tools to
deal with novel circumstances that our
ancestors
did not know anything about but that the
rate of change has become
so high that there is no conceivable way
for us to keep up with it
and what we are effectively watching
even in principle that um you know the
very fact that you can say
the environment that we live in is not
the one that we were born into
that's way too fast you may be able to
make a discrete jump
you know human beings are capable of
moving from one habitat
to another and figuring out one time
what the rules of the new habitat are
but a habitat that is constantly in
motion
and has become utterly arbitrary with
respect to even the most fundamental
uh characteristics is not something to
which we can be well adapted which is
causing us
sounds like a powerful argument for
conservatism
it is yeah i know i understand well i do
understand i do understand that that is
to the degree that i'm conservative in
my outlook that is that
is the reason it's like look i
wanna i've kept up you know like i've
transformed myself multiple times over
the years and i was taken out by this
illness and it
isn't obvious to me that i can catch up
again i've caught up a lot and i've
watched my peers
my high school classmates my university
classmates and
i've seen i've seen people who don't
have one transformation in them
they're people who they adapt to the
high school environment and that's
it that's where they are for the rest of
their life they peak at 17
they're done they don't change then i've
seen people who can manage one
transformation
i've seen people much rarer who can
manage two or three but
after that it's like it's it gets
you massive drop-off in probability with
every demand for transformation
and now like i find myself now i have to
rely on my son for doing some of my
technological chores
and i hate that because i stayed on top
of it for so long but i got sick and i
fell out and
it isn't obvious to me that i can
clamber back in it's very difficult
well if you'll take some advice from a
friend and i'm not even sure
um i'm not sure i even have it fully
formulated but
the thing you described earlier in the
conversation
the amount of effort it takes for you
to get to the point where you can be
productive in the day
the amount that is riding on your doing
it
the number of people who are listening
to you
and who basically need your influence
in their life and you know in some sense
it you know it is it's it's a
mythological story and i know you will
have
spotted that a thousand times over but
just the the herculean effort the
tremendous amount that's riding on it
and the degree
to which you're you're paying some uh
inhuman price in order just to continue
playing your role is profound and so the
advice
to the extent that i have see how you
can see that
it shocks me that you say that i mean
that isn't to say i you disagree no
it seems like that from inside here well
i mean i think you know uh but i could
but i can't
having said that i still can't believe
it
so what i think i would do in your shoes
and what i
hope you will do is you will you know
i don't think there's anything about
that story that isn't right i think
you're
you're reporting honestly how hard it is
and
i know because i've seen it in person
and everywhere else
i've seen the effect that you're having
on people and i know how important it is
in keeping them out of trouble and
steering them in the right direction and
giving them hope
and so what i would hope
is that instead of reinventing yourself
again or updating yourself that
you would figure out what the efficient
way of showing up in the world in that
role
is and
i hope that we're having this
conversation
i seem to be able to do this so i can do
this and so that's what i'm doing and i
have this book coming out and we'll see
how that
goes but i mean i think you know
i know your audience and they will
they'll accept you any way you can show
up for them and i think you know
the key thing is to figure out how to
get out of the predicament of having to
go through that herculean struggle every
day yeah well it's beyond i've been
struggling with it for two years i can't
get out of it i can't well i mean
i'm out of it to some degree i'm living
at home again i'm not in the hospital
but the reason i'm not in the hospital
is because
there's nothing that can be done for me
in the hospital like there's no point in
me going to a hospital it will just make
it worse
when i wake up in the morning like any
sensible person would go to the
emergency room and say look this is
there's just
this just isn't possible but it's
irrelevant because
all that will happen and i've been in
like four hospitals so i know
all that happens is i made much worse
and so i live in 15 minute increments
fundamentally wow
well um i i
i hope you can detect how uh many people
are rooting for you it's mind-boggling
it's and it's it's it's
it's un it's life preserving
that fact and i can't believe it even
after this last london times interview
the the amount of support that came
pouring in is just
unbelievable i can't i can't wrap my
head around it
i don't get it well but there it is
you know there it is but i mean it makes
sense you know because those of us who
have been
uh on your team or paying attention to
you for
the last several years um
know who you are and i think in some
sense
your enemies know what you are they know
that a voice like yours
carries a tremendous amount of weight
that their fictions
will not survive in the context of
a countervailing force like that and so
that's why
they come after you the way that they do
um
but you know the fact is people are
getting wiser over time
they're recognizing what an attack looks
like
you know at some level they vary a
little bit
aesthetically but the overall picture is
the same
there's a new one planned apparently so
the next thing
yeah the next thing this is something
that hasn't happened yet but is
apparently coming
a financial expose of my my uh
uh my i don't know economic existence
so you know which will be accompanied by
claims that i'm exploiting everyone
and and and well
yes they're going to come after you for
succeeding and for people
doing you know what what they can in
order to well i live
going i live such a symbolic existence i
drink
sparkling water and nothing else ever
and i eat nothing but meat ever
and so my luxuries this is so com car
it's so
absurd my luxuries have been
high-end toothpicks and sparkling water
[Laughter]
well i sometimes wonder when i look at
attacks on on you if
the idea is this there are certain
number of people
who haven't spent any time listening to
you yet
and if they did they would quickly
gather
that you're not what your enemies are
portraying you as so the idea is
there has to be a constant stream of
uh suggestions that there's something
deeply wrong with you
in order to get people not to check in
with that question
you know it's like um you know julian
assange
right the number of things that have
been said about julian assange
that would make you think well i don't
know what's going on there but
something is doing something yes right
right and so
the idea is it has the stink that they
create around you
or julian assange or another figure that
they regard as very dangerous
uh has to be sufficient to drive most
people away from even
checking for themselves and i don't
think it's working in your case but
um but i do think well so far it doesn't
seem to but you know there's always the
possibility that it'll be the next one
that'll work and
it's not like i have any shortage of
things wrong with me
there are things wrong with me you know
now whether they're ethical things or
not that's a whole different question
but
like nobody has a nobody has a uh
what no one has an untrammeled
conscience that's for sure
so and i'm not too worried about the
economic attack i mean i
i'll just make my if it gets out of hand
i'll just make all my finances public i
mean
i've never made any um
apologies for being an evil capitalist
so i think actually all the things i've
done i've tried to
use market forces to modify because i
think it's a really good source of
feedback
you know like i've produced these um
processes to help people plan and assess
their personalities and
you know we thought about giving them
away for free but free is actually a
really bad
price and once you start making things
and starting to
put them out in the environment you find
out very rapidly that pricing is very
complex and
you have to get the price right and free
is not the right price
first of all if people will only
use it if it's free it might actually
not be any good
and that's a signal so
why not use that signal that's that's
how it's appeared to me and then you
have to
make the thing sustain itself so it has
to generate some income
and anyhow that that
from what i've heard that's the next
thing that's going to happen
so yeah um if you
look we should stop pretty quick i guess
although i'm really enjoying this and we
will
definitely do it again i would really
like that i had a very fun conversation
with you it's so nice to
talk about what are essentially
scientific hypotheses i miss that so
much
um because i don't have my graduate
students anymore
um your life has changed dramatically
um if you could have
taken a route i guess i'm asking you
know would you do it again
and i do but i don't want to ask that in
a cliched way
and maybe it's a stupid question because
you just don't know but
no are you okay yeah yeah
i mean you know on the one hand if i
think about it logically would i do it
again
in a heartbeat there are a few things i
might do
slightly differently but i'm not even
compelled
you know i think uh it went pretty well
in light of what the uh the forces
in play were but you know the
the thing that we've lost is security
right and you the world
i mean people might you got a settlement
from the university
but that was a trivial proportion of
your future
or your mutual future earnings it was
nothing it was enough so you didn't
starve to death immediately but that was
all
right um you know and if if i'm honest
about it we were forced to move
out of our home to a different city
we uprooted our children's lives which
was
quite disruptive but
i really don't feel there was
any choice i don't you know if i if i
think about it as a matter of choice i
cannot
find the circuit that would have done
anything differently and
um i'm not all i can say is
our lives are full of purpose
and we're doing fine the absence of
security is something i think about a
lot
but um but
yes i would say there wasn't any choice
nor should there have been
and i'm not i'm not sorry i made the
choices i did in the slightest
well you look good man and you look if
you don't mind me saying you look
different than you did when i saw you
before
well i'm older now well but there's a
year i've noticed this in
my clinical clients when they when they
integrate
their aggression their faces harden
and they they look determined all of a
sudden instead of questioning and
you look like that more than you did now
some of that's from getting older but
not all of it it's
well i think uh you know if i'm
understanding you correctly it's
probably a lot about
um you know getting catapulted into the
big leagues
and learning to to play that role
it's um you know it's trial by fire but
certainly it's been fascinating and
i'm looking forward to seeing what comes
next
famous last words
[Laughter]
yeah that's ominous coming from you
jordan look it was great to see you
say say hi to heather for me i sure will
and uh
i can't tell you how relieved
we were to hear that tammy had recovered
and that you were
back and i know it's a rough road but um
hang in there brother we need you and
um there are so many people who are
um just thrilled that you uh
you you've come back from hell to to
rejoin the battle
all right so soon we'll talk again great
be well jordan
[Music]
you